>>Jim: You need to go
to www.sparknotes.com.
>>Narrator: Jim Wilson, an English
teacher for thirty three years,
is a self proclaimed old dog,
trying to learn new tricks.
>>Jim: When I first came to
this classroom nine years ago,
there was a computer
here, and I actually had
to be taught how to turn it on.
That's where I've come from.
>>Narrator: Here in Freedom,
Pennsylvania, an old railroad town
on the Ohio River, Freedom Area High
School is two years into a quest
to go high tech, and Mr. Wilson is
on a crash course in modern teacher.
>>Jim: I'm looking for you
to get the pictures in.
I'm looking for you
to get the music in.
I'm looking for you--
>>Narrator: Today, his sophomores
are making PowerPoint presentations
on the history and culture
behind Charles Dickens'
"A Tale of Two Cities."
>>Ben: In the beginning of the year,
we had a lot of typing projects,
you know, like writing
stories, stuff like that.
Throughout the course of the year,
we've kinda expanded to PowerPoints
and video presentations
and stuff like that.
It's actually gotten really fun.
>>Jim: My main fears were, I think,
the same fears as every old person.
First of all, I fear change a little
bit because I did it so many years,
you know, and I was so
comfortable with what I was doing.
And the second fear I still
think is a legitimate fear,
in that I'm heading into an arena
where the students know more
than I do and that's a scary thing.
>>Narrator: Slowly but surely,
Mister Wilson is overcoming his fear.
>>Jim: All right, don't panic,
don't panic, don't panic, do this.
>>It's absolutely changed
the way I teach.
I think I've given up some of
the control and become more
of a facilitator, as opposed to,
"This is the way you write the paper.
This is what you have to do."
I think I've become more of somebody
who will guide them through it,
rather than grab them by the
neck and drag them through it.
>>What do you want to look up?
>>Student: Or French
government, anything.
>>Jim: It's the French
revolution, it's pretty friendly.
What else do you want
me to do for you here?
>>Narrator: Conveniently, some
of his best tech support
comes from students.
>>Student: No, no, no, don't
use that, it won't work.
>>Jim: A lot of times,
I'll just say, "Hey,
who in this class knows how to?"
And they'll go, "Oh, I'll
show you how to do this."
>>Student: Like, we
need the Geek Squad.
>>Student: Larry should
be on the Geek Squad.
>>Student: You should
>>Narrator: The next step for Mister
Wilson is better lesson planning.
>>Jim: I've had a lot of
assignments blow up in my face
that I thought were gonna be good.
>>Narrator: All with a little help
from tech integration coach, Tom.
>>Tom: Now it's just a
matter of fine tuning...
>>Jim: A couple of years from
now, I would like to first
of all be competent enough and
competent is the correct word,
that I feel very comfortable walking
in, saying, "Here's the assignment."
Because right now, you know,
sometimes I give the assignment
and go, "Okay, what's going next?"
you know.
>>Now you're challenging me, and I
want you to know that--
>>And the second thing I'd
like to be able to do is
with confidence say,
"You need some help?
Here, I can show you how to do that."
And in a couple of years, I
think I will be able to do that.
>>Student: That is such
a great idea, yeah.
That works.
>>Okay.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org